now let's apply the formula we came up
with the last video sometimes known as
the Einstein velocity addition formula
and we'll see that it's a it's a pretty
neat thing so let's say so this is once
again me floating in space my frame of
reference is just the s frame of
reference let's say my friend over here
she's flying away from me her velocity
let's give it some numbers let's say
she's flying away from me with a
velocity of let's say 0.7 C so 7/10 of
the speed of light or 70% of the speed
of light and let's say this this third
character right over here let's say
they're flying towards me so let me
change the direction the velocity vector
so let me erase that so that doesn't
look like a pure black but I think you
can it looks fairly erased so there you
go and let me give the velocity vector
in the other direction so the velocity
vector this character is flying towards
me at let's say so U is going to be
equal to since flying towards me X is
decreasing with time it's let's say it's
negative negative 0.5 C so flying
towards me at half the speed of light
and once again both of these velocities
are given in my frame of reference now
if we were in a Newtonian world or if we
use the Galilean transformations and
this is released to something on your
highway if I'm on a highway and if I'm
going in one direction at 70 miles an
hour and someone is coming towards me at
50 miles an hour it'll look to me like
they are coming towards me at 120 miles
per hour where you would essentially add
these two together and so if we were in
a Newtonian world this person is flying
at 0.7 C and this person is flying this
way at 0.5 C you would in a Newtonian
world say okay from this point of view
it will look like this blue character is
approaching at 0.7 C plus 0.5 C or at
1.2 times the speed of light which we
know violates the laws of the universe
and that's where this formula is really
handy actually let me even make the
spaceship point in this direction just
so we don't get confused so the
spaceship is going in is going in that
direction just like that once again the
mag
to the velocity coming towards me is
half the speed of light I put the
negative there so it's coming towards me
that it's going it's that X is
decreasing over time well lucky for us
in the last video we just we came up
with this Einstein velocity addition
formula so let's apply it from this
friend's frame of reference the S prime
frame of reference the velocity of this
character which is change in X prime
over change in T is going to be this so
what do we have here so U is the blue
velocity in my frame of reference so
that is negative 0.5 C V is my friend's
frame of reference the frame of
reference that we're trying to get the
velocity in so that's 0.7 C so zero let
me do it in that color so that is 0.7 C
and then on top of U V over C squared so
once again U is negative 0.5 C I know I
wrote it really small and then and then
V is 0.7 C so what is this going to be
equal to on the numerator negative 0.5 C
minus 0.7 C that's going to be negative
our numerator right over here is going
to be negative 1.2 C and this is the
velocity that you would expect if we
were dealing in a Newtonian world this
person says hey this person looks like
they're coming towards me at 1.2 times
the speed of light that would that's
what our Galilean transformations would
give us but luckily we have all this
business at the bottom that keeps us
from violating from violating the
absoluteness
of the velocity of light this notion
that nothing can travel faster than the
speed of light
because in an our denominator we're
going to get 1 minus let's see 0.5 C
times zero point seven see let's see 0.5
times 0.7 is going to be 0.3 so zero
point three I could say zero point three
zero if I live but I'll just write zero
point three
c-squared and it'll be a negative have a
negative times a positive so I could put
the negative there but if I'm
subtracting a negative that's just going
to be a positive and I'm just going to
divide by C squared and so that cancels
out and so notice we're going to be
dividing negative 1.2 C by something
that's slightly larger than 1.2 so this
is going to be negative 1.2 C over 1.3
1.3 and so lucky for us this is going to
be less than C or in this absolute value
is going to be less than C so it's going
to be it's going to calculator out so if
we have I'll just so if we have one
point two divided by one point three
this is equal to approximately zero
point nine two so this is going to be
approximately negative zero point nine
two C which is cool it it kind of goes
with our let me write it over here so
this Delta X prime over delta T prime is
negative zero point nine two C so it
makes sense that from our friends frame
of reference the ship will look like
it's approaching her faster than it from
my frame of reference it looks like it's
approaching me and my frame of reference
it looks like it's coming to me at half
the speed of light and her frame of
reference it looks like it's coming at
0.92 times the speed of light the
negative is just specifying the
direction but we didn't violate the
fundamental postulate of special
relativity that nothing can go faster
than the speed of light and the speed of
light is absolute so this is pretty cool
I've often even thought about making a
video game somehow where you leverage
this where things are flying in
different relative velocities but you
but special relativity applies